Hello and welcome to this next video in our series. In this we are going to be doing some
of the coding in order to get the perception component to pass information to the state tree.
So here I am back in the AI site character and what I'm going to do is I'm going to come
over to the components and where it says AR perception I'm going to right-hand click
and we have an option to add an event. Now we have a number of different events here
but what you'll find is a few of these are all firing at the same time they just provide us
different data. It'll either provide us details of all of the actors that they're attracting
or it will provide us just the ones that have changed. And that's the one we're going
to work with. So we are going to use the on target perception updated. And you'll see that
this returns us two pins. The actor which was updated and a stimulus structure. Okay
so to start with the first thing I'm going to do is save out the stimulus to a variable.
So I will right-hand click on stimulus and I will go promote to variable. That's just going
to allow us to easily access it through the rest of the checks. Next thing that I want to do
is I want to check to see if we've seen the player. So I'm going to drag off of the actor
and I'm going to type equals and I'm going to get player character. I'm going to plug that into
the equals while hold down b to get a branch up. Plug that in there and connect that up there.
And do a little bit of tidying up and I'm going to add in a comment.
Now next up we are going to want to check to see what type of sense was triggered.
Now in this case it doesn't particularly matter because we only have the sight sense set up.
However I'm going to add this in now just so you'd know how to do it if you wanted to set
up multiple different senses. So I'm going to drag in and get the stimulus and if I drag off
of this there is a node that allows me to get the sense class from stimulus. I plug that in
we are returned a AI sense class reference and again from this I'm going to do an equals
and I'm going to do a drop down. Now I'm going to search for AI sense
and you can see that there is a number of different options here. Now I want you to
ignore these first ones because they are a legacy system that is still in there.
What I would like you to select is AI sense site and again I'm going to do another branch
off of the site. I want to comment in. Okay so we're just doing a check to see what sense
we have and is it sight. Now next up because this fires regardless of if we've lost sight or
seen something we're going to have to clarify to see if it has lost or seen it. So again
I'm going to grab the stimulus, get it but this time I am going to right hand click and select
split struct pin. This is going to give me a lot more options and the one that I care about
is stimulus successfully sensed because this will return a true if we've seen it and a false if we
have lost sight of it. So I'll come in and add in a branch and connect this up and let's
add another comment. How we can do something different if we've lost sight and do something
different if we've seen it. So for this what I would like to do is we already have
a layer scene variable boolean. I'm going to plug that in and this is going to tell
the system that the player has been seen and I'm going to do the same thing on
false. However I'm going to say it's not been seen. There's one more thing that we need to do
and that is to log the last location. So you can see what we're doing here we're either
logging if we've seen the player or we haven't seen the player and we're logging across their
last location. Come in here and comment and mark the player as seen and the next one is
mark the player as no longer. Okay and with that done let's test this out.
So I'm going to jump back into the level. We have our character here and I'm going to press
play and again use the apostrophe so I can see his view and at the moment he's logged me and now
he's following after me. If I go behind one of the walls you can see that he now goes to
our last known location. So just do that again until he travels to my last known location
until he sees us again. So that is up and working. Now it's a little bit
finicky because I've set the site to such a small area but if you set it to a larger one
so let's do that now. I'm just going to come back in and in the AI perception I'm going to
increase about a thousand to each of these and I'm going to make the peripheral vision back to 90.
Play it again if I play apostrophe and see see the character is following us.
Because we have the last known location it's a bit more robust and that brings us to the
end of our first exercise. We've set up the perception component and got it to log the
character. In the next one we're going to be looking at the noise stimulus.